hi everyone I'm David Griffin and I'm
Michael Medina where to bring you the
pen ultimate episode of arrow season 2
episode 22 streets of fire the big
episode summer glau is wearing a mask
that's too big for a head but that's
okay because later on she takes it off I
hope she keeps it off but this is a lot
going on I can play in last we got that
last episode was a little fillory much
filler in that episode this episode took
off that's the thing but last week was a
good setup for this explosion actions a
lot of action um so many places to go
let me see oh sorry let's start with
something small start with Malcolm
Merlyn yeah and Thea like take off the
mask she's my daughter something like
that you know like oh no you know very
Star Wars type moment keeps throwing
like all these look like Oh your eyes
are my my eyes at all these like get it
and Thea Thea goes and shoots him at the
end I mean now I would assume the
Malcolm Merlyn and all that armor he had
on he's probably ok she was aiming more
in this area not at his face so I'm sure
he's okay I mean we saw what happened at
the end of last season so I think he's
gonna be okay seems to be hard to kill
so that's that's that's gonna be okay
but I'm curious to know just what his
endgame is right now because I mean
obviously you know what he's capable of
right and so he seems like he genuinely
after what happened to Tommy and you
know him losing his wife right and stuff
Thea that's really all he has left yeah
I'm really all phia has left yeah except
for Oliver so it was interesting to see
like you know what happens what that
dynamic is because I couldn't help but
think and maybe this is just me yeah but
I was thinking what if you know castilla
right now is she's a difficult she's
wandering she's just not purpose she's
exact does every club anymore she does
love was taken away and we're probably
destroyed oh but I was wondering like
what if you know she goes bad what if
she what if Malcolm takes her under his
wing you know maybe she becomes like you
know Oliver's Merlin right maybe it's
not her dad maybe it's not Malcolm maybe
it's the yeah you know specifically so
though yeah that was good i like those
parts i mean it's
little funny little silly i mean ii know
ii just like in the subway buyers l this
mega city with half a million people
ain't nobody in that subway i'm like
really you know it's always team always
an arrow you have to have steam coming
out too dangerous city you have to it's
it's hot you know their confidence hot
so that was a good moment let's talk
about a kevin alejandro brother blood
himself making a making an exit kind of
sad we're not both kind of sad about
that yeah i mean i know we both like him
on yeah yeah great oh yeah but we also
like I'm in the show yeah as well and
stuff I know when we were watching
though we were a little I don't know I
know like a little disappointed like
with house brother blood was yeah we're
trying to work we're wondering him put
it out to you like what's up with him
going good at the end this dude kills
his dad you know as you have to to
become brother bloody commits an act of
patricide he's kind of weird to his mom
ore Ang's living in that mental facility
I mean he doesn't seem like he's a good
guy like you were saying he was going to
create something new maybe a new city
with like a twisted version exactly what
i thought was like you know so the fact
that I mean maybe that's the thing maybe
that was his conflict with Slade was
that look I don't want to destroy the
whole city but I want to build a new one
and slay just wants to kill everything
he wants it to be ashes what he said and
which is not surprising because I think
we all kind of knew this was coming
anyways and the blood was a pawn but I
mean I like brother blood and I knew
this was slightly different yeah we're
used to seeing the comic books but I
would have liked to have seen him a
little bit more nutty you know what I
mean you know the mass and certainly not
getting killed at the end yeah that was
sad I mean cuz we didn't he was in the
season the first part a little more yeah
they took a break he wasn't there as
Moyer was running for mayor like you saw
him every now and then you see him a lot
more at the end but now he's gone this
is true I mean it's great that they're
you know they kill off characters you
know we had um and but then they find
their way back so here you come back go
back Tommy hasn't come back yes I'm
hoping Tommy he stays dead but I mean
yeah so it was it was good it was just
sad to see him go yeah in summer glau is
ravager we don't like her with the mask
do not it's just her office awesome i
love the swords leather leather rate
with it's just that mass on the helmet I
think it's too big for a head or
something it makes your head look big
hear us like I think it works for
Deadpool but on her just maybe it's just
her frame right yeah looks a little
lame right but I hope she just I'd like
to see you just rocket without with the
long hair I mean there's some scenes
we're gonna talk about this next week I
talked about some spoilers later on in
the review their knots ploys we Mike and
I kind of slow analyze a trailer for
next week we'll talk about the end and I
warn you before we talk about that in
case you don't want to know about that
kind of stuff but moving on let's talk
about I'll see the sisters yeah the
sister so Sara and Laurel have a nice
meeting black Canary's revealed she goes
deep takes off the wig kicks off the
mass has a nice revealed not before
Laurel figures it out she's like with
her like Sarah like really you couldn't
know whether I mean come on simple like
everything that gets hurt yeah and I
mean it might have seemed a little corny
when she's like giving her the hero pep
talk or whatever but I mean it was good
at the same don't like Leigh turn off
the cops like handsome blonde just took
a baby out of right Billy that girl's a
hero it's like it's a little cheesy hey
ever hear of it I am but it was good
though I still enjoyed it i'm as cheesy
as it was i still liked it so I mean it
was nice so we know the reveal she goes
in saves about why is it so it's so
cliche so comic book cliche hey if
you're a mom or dad you know parents out
there the first thing I would assume you
would grab out when your house is
brewing down is your baby you wouldn't
like gleave just like Oh where's not
even family grad their slippers got the
phone like backdraft fire movie superman
there's always a baby in the house like
who's leaving the babies in that in the
crib you just forget that it's there but
anyway that was uh that was funny so I
guess the big thing now I guess the
other got to move into is our main group
so Oliver Felicity Diggle doing some
he's basically Driving Miss Daisy now I
mean he's driving you know get in the
car and of course everybody else which
includes Slade and them so they were all
first in the beginning trying to get
this thing from STAR Labs a cure for the
mirakuru yeah yeah that was pretty cool
I mean I've or guy stuck in the car yeah
okay by the way I'm here I'm sorry I'm
here Miley see that it's been
intercepted by leads henchman yep which
is kind of cool and stuffing and so
they're doing their thing obviously they
had a little run-in with a Ravager
you know Isabel the brain when they ran
over cars she got up kind of Terminator
style ya know but no I liked him in this
episode I thought Felicity had a good
moment with Oliver or whatever in what
looked like the watchtower look like you
could in the water never watch
smallville they don't watch tower they
kind of looked like that I notice the
cameras I mean on the the hand the
camera always every time they touch
Oliver would touch is like the camera
zoomed in on the hand like pay attention
i love love triangle coming up people
this is a CW don't forget what channel
we're on right before shadowing for
something that was said later on when uh
brother blood tells him that you know
he's going to kill someone that you
really love I know the question is who
does Oliver love all right let's let's
start let's start typing now start
typing what is all over love above all
houses at Thea is it phyllisha is it
Laurel maybe Sarah maybe Sarah he's got
single me maybe see because I Robinson
maybe I always forget her name what's
her name Cynthia whose character oh um
in charge of Argus I always forget come
on Amanda wall made of Waller oh yeah it
was Amanda Waller I don't know maybe heh
so many ladies who knows a lazy s so
that was interesting um we didn't so
Oliver really didn't do much fighting
this episode yeah he's fine with it yeah
i'm guessing the big Deathstroke fight
is gonna be at the end you know we have
obviously said what Argus is the Argus
Argus is the the military group that
Amanda Waller's controlling there in a
level of town he has till dawn because
episode ended just on you know done with
a you know Thea shootie alkem which it's
not surprising given the fact that like
a big two-part finale basically exactly
like you know we had our little prelude
I guess last week and stuff and this is
kind of like part one so so you knew it
was gonna end like that so you know nice
little cliffhanger but all in all I mean
I thought the action was there even
though we didn't see a lot of Oliver
fighting right yeah but um oh yeah
definitely lot of action letter a lot of
action um we're also going back to the
Cure and stuff we see this moment where
you know they get Roy from I guess
you're really busy last oh you know
Oliver's kind of conflicted like he
wants to inject them with me cure
Felicity's like no don't do that
whatever so he's a little you know but
then when he gets off the phone with
Waller right you know and finds out
what's gonna happen to stuff that
they're basically just gonna be ready to
he just does it right you know so kinda
ends which again kind of leads towards
what we saw for next week which is a bit
of a spoiler yeah that shouldn't be yeah
what are we're gonna get a little
section at the end here where we talk
about everything so I mean what's uh see
what else do we have covered all the all
the all basically the the major events
that happen you know Laura let's not
forget about laurels dad also gets
promoted back up to the tax got his
detective badge again I mean he's he's
basically in charge so the guys like
well you know more with us than I do so
he makes make the call Mike really it
might have seemed a little hokey or
whatever but it's a good scene
nonetheless because it does show the
police department embracing kind of I
guess arrow as you know to fight him ask
you need a mask yeah so that's kind of
cool and may help Oliver make that
transition from being known as a
vigilante actually hero yeah he's not to
hero you need but the one you you know
you know he's going to art I Rosie is
healing this city yeah he put his own
line on himself we said I have failed
this yeah he used his own line on
himself for guys not doing but
Felicity's there to bring him back up so
exactly let's go into our predictions
and just a conversation about the finale
it's been a great seasons been exciting
teasing a lot going on we're also going
to get into don't call it spoilery
because if you watch the show on
television you see the clip after were
like next week on the CW and so we but
we kind of slow the trailer down a
little bit kind of went frame by frame
on some of the scenes if you don't want
all the details and maybe you know we'll
see you next week for the finale which
we can't wait for but it's kind of going
to that so in the trailer which I kind
of you were saying I wish you didn't
give this away we see that we see Roy
see ya we seized his ok live and well I
mean I guess we didn't think II was
gonna die not really surprised but
nonetheless it's like you kind of you
know he's got the mask on yeah Anna hood
and he's got his red hood on what you
need the hood you gotta have new this so
no one makes hello yeah I mean and it
looked like he has a quiver Nikki's
carry on yeah so red arrow ours this way
them a picture them like struck up a
street like because yeah even though
they do show you don't really see what
he's capable of doing right you don't
know if he was completely cured of the
mirakuru maybe he's still retained a
little something right who knows we also
see of course my well I have a lot of
I like I like the ladies but we also
have Nisa is coming back he's fighting
yeah there's a scene where you see her
like pull on the hair of a Ravager no
Isabel rochev she's got the mask on
again unfortunate wish you would take
the mask off and you see them fine so
it's going to be a great yeah fight at
the end a great duel between those two
girls then also that scene when you see
Roy and Oliver you can see what looks
like it could be some members of the
league beside us at all fight together
yeah helping him out so it's gonna get a
little nutty Rex we know that uh she's
gone Sarah went away yeah hey where'd
you go she's like I had to go away for a
while like we know she's probably went
to knee so since you got to go see an
old friend yeah probably asking for help
she's gonna come and help out it's gonna
be great to see her it's good to see
where all these characters are after
next week where they absolutely
absolutely because the thing is today
going back to Malcolm instead obviously
it's safe to say he's probably gonna
come he's probably gonna be ok but like
what's his reasoning for being there you
know he did appear earlier in the series
left the League of Assassins cuz wishes
after him or will be after if he knows
of his whereabouts oh it's like what's
his game what's his right now this his
whole attempt the city's kind of failed
like what's he up to now like do they
know that he's okay that he's right I
have it sized the deal with that so the
assassins comes next week its mission to
see how that interaction goes and also
to I guess maybe some of you might be
wondering like why we didn't make I
didn't talk too much about the
flashbacks this weekend I guess yeah cuz
the first practice we didn't really
reveal a whole lot I mean you got to see
them yeah the plot on the attacking
Amazo the ship is still going on Slade
catches them you know trying to find the
you know the mirakuru and all that but
like it so it goes in rescue right and
we like you know his Russian friend is
funny I think he's great so much fun
he's awesome but like nothing really I
mean I think everything's gonna be
revealed next week we're gonna see
everything so we didn't going to tell
that but I mean those are thoughts those
are our predictions of course we'd love
to hear what you think I mean let us
know if you watch the trailer for next
week what you think about nice are
returning and just like the whole League
of Assassins like it's going to be fun
yeah kind of how the season's over even
though man it's been a long season
October to the almost like the midway
point of May it's like whew it's crazy
the only three episodes i was saying
this early how we started talking about
like what we were looking forward to
doing it 0
preview july's that look after every
comic comics you know a comic con about
three months are going to have a sizzle
reel yeah we're gonna do it we'll do a
preview video probably then two and then
you know just a journey the scheme which
is great so as always you know that's
what we thought of this week's episode
you come chat with us think hero com or
also on this YouTube page just think
hero pro we're also on Twitter dennis
michael on myself and talk to us about
arrow or any of the shows that you're
watching right now agents of shield if
you're liking that to you know we'll see
but that's at think hero i'm at griffin
de i'm at mr. michael Alexis and you can
also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans be
sure to LIKE subscribe spread the word
social media and we can't wait to talk
to you next week about the season finale
season 2 finale of arrow see y'all next
week
you